aujourd'hui les modèles de la virilité
chez les hanches et les millénium c'est
justement d'exhiber son physique pour
paraître verrier qu'est ce que tu en
penses de sa et caisses que rousseau
plate on penserait de de ça parce que là
tu vas nous dire que le pur pour toi est
viril et pour moi également c'est plutôt
nourrir sa famille de se réveiller tôt
plutôt que de montrer qu'on a un beau
corps parce qu'à un moment façon quand
tu dis est viril battue sera face à une
situation va falloir qu proulx donc
qu'est ce que tu penses de ses modèles
de la vérité pour les jeunes c'est
exhibe cette équipe qui est très féminin
seulement ouais ça mélange beaucoup de
paramètres actuels la question suppose
donc je vais y aller progressivement
parce qu'on ya l'affluence de l'image on
est dans une société de l'image et on
pourrait s'interroger sur ce que ça
signifie ce besoin d'apparaître tu vois
là ça serait pas rousseau platon ce
serait plutôt sartre et le regard des
autres on se pose toujours la question
de savoir comment on est perçu et même
les gens qui disent je me plie de savoir
ce que pensent les autres je sais très
bien le point c'est que c'est les
premiers qui ne sentit ce pas justement
là c'est hypocrite mais on a toujours le
souci de ce qu'on pense de nous par
exemple si on va dire quelque chose que
tu n'es pas tu vas vouloir corriger la
vérité de tout ce qu'il te justifier
donc tu vas pas dire je m'en fiche je
regarde les autres parce que tu vas
reprendre quelqu'un quand il dit quelque
chose de faux sur toi par exemple donc
c'est pas vrai qu'on s'en fiche c'est
vrai c'est qu'on peut être conscient que
c'est pas si important que ça qu'il ya
des choses qui ont plus de valeur et
c'est ça c'est par rapport à la question
de l'image ensuite y'a aussi le besoin
de se prouver des choses de se donner
une identité on est aussi dans une
société société libérale dans laquelle
identité c'est assez mal vu parce que on
a cette espèce d'idéal de mélange d
identité ou conserver les anciennes
identité pareil c'est ringard c'est
dépassé ces réactionnaires donc qu'est
ce qu'on fait on va se trouver des
identités de substitution et le sport
permet aussi de se conférer une identité
parce que c'est un mode de vie parce que
c'est une manière de s'alimenter parce
que ce sont des codes et tout ce qui est
je veux dire habitus comme disait
bourdieu est à dire des comportements
qui sont ancrées dans nos habitudes cela
nous confère une identité et souvent on
s'identifie comme sportif on s'identifie
comme clay tout comme body builder ou
comme instagram heure par exemple et si
on nous enlève ça la leçon qu'on ait
plus rien et sartre disait on n'est pas
resté on existe ce qui veut dire qu'à
tout moment on peut être autre chose que
ce qu'on est à un moment donné se donner
une image c'est se donner une identité
et donc moi je pense qu'on a un besoin
humain ancré dans l'âme de savoir qui on
est et savoir qui on est parfois ça
passe par montrer ce qu'on est aux
autres parce que on s'identifie aussi
par rapport au regard des autres on
s'émancipe jamais du regard des autres
parce que même quand on dit ce qui
compte ce n'est pas ce que pensent les
autres c'est ce que moi je pense oui
mais à ce moment là on sait analyse soi
même comme un autre c'est à dire c'est
comme si on sortait de soi même pour
ceux observés pour se voir et tu es
aussi très bien placé pour savoir que
des fois on a une perception déformée de
soi même dans le sol marin cas là ils
vont être vraiment décor l'athlète ils
vont avoir l'impression qu'ils sont gros
qui sont rares qui seront maigres on a
une perception qui est déformé le
premier cas c'est que on perçoit le
manque à travers notre propre perception
on est prisonnier notre perception le
fait d'apparaître aux autres de se
montrer des snacks rôle avant d'exhiber
séisme ceci le besoin d'être rassurés
par rapport à la perception des autres
les autres ont sur nos toits on va être
complexé on va attendre que les autres
nous rassurent ils nous disent voir quel
beau corse a déjà du travail créé les
citations c'est valorisant donc il ya
aussi une angoisse très moderne très
contemporaine de savoir ce qu'on vaut de
prouver ce qu'on est de savoir ce qu'on
veut et on passe par le regard des
autres pour se donner soi-même de la
valeur moi quand je rentre quand je sors
dans la rue quand les gens me
reconnaissent et toujours ouais c'est
toujours un moment extraordinaire même
ça m'arrive de parler j'ai parlé 45t
parfois avec un follower à monoprix
tueur à côté
et quand on a comme un terreau négatives
qui sont les règles du jeu de ce genre
de réseau les gens le prennent mal et
qualifie cette personne deux hectares ce
qu'est ce que tu en penses encore une
fois c'est oui de l'hypersensibilité le
besoin d'être d'être validée à 100%
le fait de pas tolérer qu'on puisse ne
pas être d'accord aussi alors il ya
aussi ce ce phénomène la disette alors
on est toujours plus ou moins prisonnier
de sa perception est prisonnier de sa
pensée donc on va avoir tendance à
croire que l'autre doit penser comme
qu'on a la bonne pensée la bonne manière
de voir les choses le bon point de vue
et donc si quelqu'un vient de dire je
suis pas d'accord
on va pas se dire ah il n'est pas
d'accord ce serait intéressant de savoir
pourquoi et puis après j'ai avec moi
puis après tu crois que tu laisses
obligé non plus de prendre en compte
absolument tout ce qu'on dit mais
simplement laisser la parole à personne
s'exprimer mais il ya ce truc de se dire
elle n'est pas d'accord avec moi donc
elle se trompe et c'est elle se trompe
je vais soit lui prouver que l apport je
le pourrai c'est moi qui ai raison et
par elle ou alors je vais la qualifier
effectivement d'un acteur de rageux peu
importe bon après il ya les vrais rageux
jordan c'est des gens qui sont animés
par le ressentiment et qui ont besoin
pour se valoriser de dévaloriser les
autres moi je pense que les personnes
qui critiquent sur les vidéos n'ont
quasiment pas d'importance ce qui compte
c'est le contenu et même je dirais de ne
pas relever les critiques qui ne servent
pas à nous améliorer qui servent à nous
empêcher d'avancer il ya des critiques
légitimes parce qu'elles viennent de
personnes qui sont bien là encore sonné
je pense que je sais pas si t'as pas à
mon enfant ou un terme à leurs amis
voilà que tu te fais une critique bon
déjà il va il a pas consultés il va te
faire une critique en douceur plus te
connais bien personnellement voilà donc
tu vas pouvoir donner de la valeur à
cette critique parce que tu sais qu'elle
est fondée et tu sais qu'elle n'est pas
animé par le ressentiment et la
malveillance et puis ensuite à des
critiques qui sont là simplement pour
essayer de détruire et ses critiques là
si tu lis réagi si tu leur accorde de la
valeur tu va les nourrir tu va leur
donner une puissance qu'elle n'avait pas
au départ on te répond pour être pour
moi la réponse donc si toi tu es dans
ton truc et que je dis pas que tu est
sur d'avoir raison mais si tu essaies de
faire les choses bien et que des
personnes et celle de temps d'empêcher
un moi j'estime que la meilleure
attitude à avoir c'est de pas en finir
qu'on est de continuer à avancer ne pas
s'arrêter hier imagine ce que ce serait
la vie si à chaque fois que quelqu'un
pense quelque chose de mal en te voyant
tu devais arrêter pour aller te
justifier auprès du ballon les gens
pensent ce qu'ils pensent comme on en
parlait tout à l'heure avec ça le regard
des autres on le maîtrise pas le regard
des autres ne dépend pas de nous là on
parlerait du stoïcisme ce qui ne dépend
pas de toi ne doit pas affecter d'accord
pourquoi parce que si tu affecté par ce
qui n'est pas de toi tu te condamne au
malheur parce que ça ne changera pas ce
qu'il n'est pas toi ne dépend pas de toi
qu'est ce que tu penses à deux de ces
gens qui prennent tellement pour argent
comptant sont tellement sont les raisons
c'est tellement larmes parce qu'ils ont
que ça que ça peut que les avis négatifs
ou ce que peuvent penser des gens
de manière négative ne peut les détruire
comme on existe à travers son image si
notre image est écornée ou si quelqu'un
ne valide pas notre image c'est la fin
du monde on repère toujours le
commentaire négatif dans l'océan des
commentaires positifs on a cessé tout
simplement de lego c'est tout simplement
légaux qui fait qu' on ne supporte pas
d'être contredit d'être critiqué on ne
supporte pas enfin quelque chose
j'allais dire de plus subtil qui est on
on voudrait que la personne
comprenne ce qu'on est même si nous on
ne sait pas c'est à dire vous ne serait
ce que la personne parce que je dirais
l'impuissance à ce qu'on offre
exactement mais la personne n'avait à
réagir à ce qu'elle voit à ce que tu
veux présent assumé à un son
interprétation il son jugement mais
choisir une personne elle pense du mal
de toi à tort admettons elle se trompe
d'ailleurs elle croit quelque chose sur
toi qui est pas vrai et elle se
construit une image négative de toi et
alors mais où est ce que c'est marqué
dans quel code dans quel manuel
d'existence c'est écrit qu'il fallait
absolument corriger toute personne qui
se trompait sur toi ne versait pas un
besoin donc on peut très bien vivre avec
et je fais quelques philosophes a dit
que si les gens apprenaient ce que
disent leurs amis de même il n'y aurait
plus de personnes mises sur terre parce
que même les amis se critiquent les
années et on connaît tous les groupes
d'amis tout en un qui va critiquer
l'autre en douce et un toit et qui à la
fin on a une roue ida de personnes qui
se sont inscrites est assez intéressant
c'est quand tu critique quelqu'un tu
fais auprès de quelqu'un d'autre donc ça
veut dire que si par hasard moi je te
critique auprès moralisateur
500 premières devrait être de me parle
pas de lui ouais c'était un truc à lui
ont valu le dire mais si cette personne
à année à un échange avec toi et
surenchérit avec le problème selon moi
c'est pas tant critiquer quelqu'un ce
que tout le monde critique du mans il y
en a quand même bâti des médias là
dessus mais c'est que la personne avec
qui tu critique quelqu'un va le répéter
à la personne critiquer alors moi c est
qu est ce que tu penses ajustement de 2
de 7,2 cette mesquinerie de la personne
avec qui tu critique quelqu'un et qui te
fait surenchérir dans ce que tu peux
dire de négatif sur quelqu'un qui après
on va pour se prendre pour jouer les
blancs dire à la personne que tu as
critiqué il a dit si a dit ça tu vas le
ce a rejoint un peu la question de
l'image et de la parole parce que
admettons tu confier un secret à
quelqu'un un secret par définition c'est
invisible si tu le gardes personne n'est
au courant donc tu ne peut pas exister
aux yeux des autres à travers ce secret
le fait d'aller le répéter ça va te
donner de la valeur à terme et images
osées des eaux c'est à dire gratu
détient une information confidentielle
titre exceptionnel hors exceptionnels
c'est un truc à vous dire on va faire
monter la cote us et tranquillement tu
vas dire l'atmosphère la cour on l'a
tous nés bien sûr et donc quand tu va
raconter ce que l'autre a dit d'intel tu
te sens exister parce que tu es porteur
d'une information qui a de la valeur
parce que tu vois tu as quelque chose
d'intéressant à dire et est donc c'est
presque une manière tu c'est de gratter
de la visibilité non dans la vie réelle
comme certains essaierait de le faire
sur les rhinois et 502 bezin s'acquitter
cela alors que si tu gardes ton secret
bah tu es tout seul avec mon secret est
la personne physique l'a confié personne
est au courant du n'existe plus et on
parlait leurs antennes de warhol doit le
fameux les 15 minutes de gloire way qui
se comprend que ça ben oui je pense qu
on m alors qu'on le dit on attention les
gens qui sont très présents sur les
réseaux sociaux parce qu'il ya des gens
qui sont pas sur les réseaux sociaux qui
en auront absolument rien à faire et ils
vont pas chercher leur quart d'heure de
gloire ils ont plutôt cherché à mener
leur existence du mieux qu'ils peuvent
mais c'est incroyable ce qu'il avait dit
parce que aujourd'hui charles
aujourd'hui même quelqu'un qui a mille
abonnés il a des gens qui le suivent des
gens qui interagit avec schiemer et ce
qu'il dit dont on peut dire qu'il a mais
qui il a assez même pas un terrain dans
le loiret la de la gloire au quotidien
donc qu'est ce qu'ils pensent de sa
quinzaine warhol pascal touzanne alors
au quotidien c'est dangereux par on
s'habitue encore une fois on s'adapte
donc une situation exceptionnelle
devient la nouvelle norme et appartient
elle est normal il faut augmenter cette
gloire il faut augmenter cette
visibilité c'est le plus petit du
chiffre en fait moi plutôt que le culte
du corps on dit souvent il ya un culte
du corps non il n'ya pas un culte du
corps il ya un respect du corps
quelqu'un qui produisent tous les jours
on va pas dire qu'il a un culte de
l'hygiène on va nous dire qu'il est
propre bon voilà c'est bien par contre
le fait de s'habituer à la notoriété à
la visibilité fait que tu vas aller
chercher toujours plus et donc je pense
qu'à un culte du nombre excellent et là
on rejoint rené guénon lui c'est un gars
qui parlait du règne de la quantité il
expliquait la modernité en termes de
quantité de matérialisme en gros c'est
la division c'est l'ego c'est la matière
c'est tout cet univers là et on existe à
travers le chiffre voilà et ce qui est
drôle c'est que je regardais la fin un
documentaire sur l'invention des réseaux
sociaux et de facebook il expliqué
qu'ils avaient mis l'option like pour
donner de l'amour aux gens d'accord le
petit instant l'air ambiant de personnes
thème voilà est donc en gros c'est pour
récolter de l'amour récolter du soutien
et quand ils ont vu bon autant ils ont
mis le dislike aussi à côté nommé
pouvait pas non plus ignorer ce que ça
allait donner et ils ont dit en fait on
s'est rendu compte que même les
personnes qui avaient beaucoup de likes
de lac était malheureuse quand elle en
recevait - mais tu fais une publication
tu vas avoir mis la x6 est d'après
temps-là 800 n'est pas bien alors qu'en
fait 800 personnes quittent on dit ouah
c'est chouette c'est énorme mais le
problème c'est que tu fais une
soustraction qu'on est vraiment dans le
règne de la quantité et tu te dis j'ai
moins de visibilité que la précédente et
ça ça va prendre malheureux c'est ça qui
après avoir finit jamais
[Musique]